hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream graveyard now
there's a second part in a six part
series of individual games and I don't
know if all the story is connecting and
meshing between the six games but I do
know that the first game that I played
butcher was pleasantly terrifying so
turn down your lights turn up your music
and get ready for an adventure now I got
to be careful that whoa well nevermind I
was about to say I got to be careful
about where I put my mouse but I'm not
gonna worry about that can I have that
come on how's that why would I want a
fruit fly oh damn it I really need to be
careful because I'm gonna get my fingers
snips nipped off unless that was just a
common thing to the butcher nah hey
how's it going there pretty birdy oh you
so sassy I well I don't want to talk to
you
oh god I have a dead bee why is there
why is this mouth just a whole
committees not maybe I'm just seeing
things okay so the thing about this game
is that there's a lot of hidden things
damn it I keep doing that stop it oh god
why don't I just wreck everything here
I'm just a maniac I'm hurricane
something markiplier whatever okay so
it's a point-and-click style adventure
game but there's a lot of things that I
could do wrong abou hi how are you you
look happy
can I make it out oh that box okay I
thought it was gonna be the box - did
snip snip oh this is nothing I can do
here do you want a deadbeat I don't
wanna tell us offer but I got a dead bee
it's really cool okay nevermind then
let's just be on my way and ignore that
that happened okay
why why is it you oh okay
I didn't even know there was a thing I
got an empty jar good [ __ ] I don't like
that bear the bear is not a good bear a
bear is unhappy hi how are you
fresh waterfowl are you okay oh you're
not a duck nevermind what am i doing
you're like a stalker
oh no bears oh no bears well I'll just
take my bear off into the woods and
become another monster again oh but I
wanna love my bear I shouldn't have
picked up the bear I guess dammit
well what am I gonna do now I got a bear
I didn't know I wasn't supposed to pick
up the bear well I don't care about hey
I got a fly in the jar that's good and
useful and stuff and gonna help me on my
adventure or something oh you wanna you
wanna you own flying is it you want to
you guys want to fly in the jar does
anybody want to fly in a jar I am just a
weirdo stomping through a graveyard
asking if anyone wants a fly in a jar or
a dead teddy bear oh okay I got a
battery I didn't know those was a good a
battery you want to fly a desire you
want teddy bear oh sorry what did I do
okay can I throw a stone at ya
well I didn't know you'd answer my
question directly it's got a creepy
alrighty then how about you back can i
bop you with a stone what did that do
why did I put a fly in the bee house was
the point of that what was the purpose
of that no I'm not gonna let this one
slide what was the purpose of that okay
when a real laser so oh so so what about
that so so what about wait what is that
wait did you get to see that there was
something like falling there I don't
know
was weird maybe who's just my moderate
my mana is so dirty and grimy from all
the spit I fling at it on a daily basis
okay so now I'm a little bit lost oh
there we go
Bing bong I have a teddy bear delivery
for the non teddy bear house hi in it
what happened oh oh okay he took one of
my teddy bears arms good for all know
what is that thing oh okay
I guess I really don't like creaking
footsteps heard from above me okay I got
a handle for the door I got a knife to
defend anyone from attacking my teddy
bear
no one's gonna attack my teddy bear not
even you weird snake butthole monster
okay I'll just be on my way away from
the clown then don't mind me as I
skedaddle away and why did I need to put
the fly in the bee house whatever hi
hello how are you I'm fine did you know
that everything's crazy it's missing an
arm hope you don't mind that oh hey
okay I got another fly in the joke oh oh
it's never happy anymore I don't keep
letting horrible things happen to it
want to be my geef no alright then
oh so the teddy bear got rejected
I guess weird oh boy am I gonna make
some more stew okay so oh I know I need
to I need to deposit this flan oh that's
right okay
oh that's right that's right give me
give me okay all right so for some
reason I need to put all the Flies in
there I don't know why but this is what
I'm doing
there's no fly over here with the crying
child I don't think yeah there's the
thing again it happened again it did it
did the thing they're flying here no
probably not okay
oh thanks teddy bear thank you oh hi let
me disturb you coz that's oh I didn't
stab you I armed you I don't think I
want to do that also why am I here take
you again why did I give that the knife
I don't think I want yeah oh it's happy
now oh it's very happy why is that
standing on that's eyes why is that do
on dad I didn't get anything okay okay
okay damn it [ __ ] okay mm-hmm no ain't
touching that I want to touch that
I do that oh no thanks
you took another oh this is so happy and
now there's party balloons everywhere
gray I did bad Oh joyous day okay so is
anything change over here no still the
same weird place still the same weird
hard on the ground did I get all the
fool did I did I get all the flies okay
oh good I got a spring well that means I
gotta go back and do everything there
God god damn it's there again see it
okay so some reason I need a spring to
do something and that something is
behind door number three which is over
here hang on unless anyone need a spring
you need a spring penis Oh
oh god I didn't know I need this blood
this why did I need the blood
am i putting the blood in here too why
do I need blood
you need blood anybody need blood oh you
need blood okay
that don't make no sense at all but I
guess I shouldn't question it all right
then so what the hell is with that this
bizarre all these point click adventures
are just a little bit bizarre on the
idea from what this mole Oh
okay so what do I do about that I have a
wooden head okay all right cool
ray what is that bird in that body oh I
did note it I did bad I've got a good
sound oh no
why did I do this why did I make this
happen
oh no oh one more fly for the pile I
guess oh I did so bad
ah I did so bad Oh No well another for
the pilot food Hey look I get sticky you
good I guess what do I do with the
sticky dew oh no oh my world
everything's hunky-dory now I'm so happy
everyone is happy good crash I guess I
Wow I shouldn't have expected much out
of bad no not not like it was bad by me
I shouldn't have expected something to
be sane at a bad dream but man those
creepy and weird good
Colleen who's so gruesome and bizarre it
was love less like hop out and scary is
scary but it was more like it just what
is going on scary which is also a really
cool kind of fear to have but anyway
this was phenomenal I'm gonna keep
playing the other parts of these games
um I probably is gonna play them all in
row because they're really really
interesting to me so there's four other
parts with four other stories i'ma play
them now there okay good there we go
alright so that was just the splash
screen intro for the developer but
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching if you haven't checked it out
check out bad dream butcher and get
ready for the next bad dream games
coming at you real soon thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you lovely good